[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 del
mundo y buena parte de Brasil despide al
Astro del fútbol Edson arantes de
nacimientos Pelé unas 230.000 personas
asistieron a la cámara ardiente en el
estadio Club Santos el cuerpo dujey
llegó al cementerio en donde sus restos
serán despedidos en una ceremonia
privada
en Estados Unidos los recientemente
elegidos representantes a la cámara y
senadores tomarán juramento de sus
cargos la cámara baja quedará en poder
de los republicanos y los demócratas del
senado lo que significa un cambio en la
relación entre la administración biden y
el legislativo tenemos reportes desde
Washington en unos minutos
y en China siguen saturados los
hospitales del país ante el constante
aumento de los casos de Kobe 19 varios
países han impuesto restricciones a Los
viajeros procedentes de ese país
asiático una medida criticada por
Beijing por calificarla de ser una
respuesta a intereses políticos
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a esta
actualización de noticias en France 24
soy Santiago López González
El cuerpo del Astro del fútbol brasileño
Edson arantes a tu nacimiento conocido
como Pelé ya llegó al cementerio de la
Ciudad de Santos donde reposará tras una
ceremonia privada a la que solo
asistirán los familiares del deportista
el cuerpo de Pelé
arribó a este lugar después de un
cortejo fúnebre por las principales
calles de la ciudad y una cámara
Ardiente de dos días a la que asistieron
cerca de 230.000 personas Fanny nos da
más detalles desde la ciudad de santos
en Brasil
es un funeral digno de un monarca como
el de la Reina Isabel 2 al que acabamos
de asistir porque en cierto modo Brasil
está despidiendo a su Rey un funeral que
él había querido que fuera Público
simpatizantes de todo el país pudieron
aplaudir sus restos en el corazón del
estadio del Santos durante 24 horas el
mismo presidente Lula visitó el lugar
esta mañana para despedir a este artista
del gol un hombre negro dijo de un
Barrio pobre que fue Coronado como
tesoro nacional y que se codeó con los
más grandes pero que se mantuvo Modesto
y modelo para muchas generaciones de
brasileños son estas generaciones padres
hijos nietos de todo el país que
acompañaron sus restos en una procesión
por la ciudad cantando y aplaudiendo
mientras el ataúd era colocado en un
camión de bomberos a este cementerio
para una ceremonia privada a la que solo
asisten sus familiares más cercanos fue
el mismo Pelé el que eligió que así
fuera porque su padre su hermano y uno
de sus hijos están enterrados aquí en el
piso nueve con Vista a la ciudad y al
estadio Santos pero en su caso su tumba
estará unos pisos más abajo para que sus
fanáticos puedan visitarlo este
cementerio ahora transformado en un
momento en un monumento histórico un
lugar de peregrinación para aficionados
de todo el mundo que quieren visitar al
rey Pelé
vamos ahora hasta Colombia allí los
líderes de la guerrilla del eln el
ejército de liberación nacional
desmintieron al presidente Gustavo Petro
quien aseguró que este grupo armado era
una de las cinco formaciones al margen
de la ley que acordaron un cese al fuego
bilateral así lo dio a conocer este
grupo guerrillero a través de un
comunicado en el que marca una amplia
diferencia entre el cese al fuego con La
tregua de Navidad que expiró el pasado 2
de enero tras el anuncio el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro convocó a una
reunión extraordinaria con el ministro
del interior el ministro de la defensa y
también con funcionarios de la oficina
del alto comisionado para la paz el eln
sostiene en la actualidad en Caracas
Venezuela una mesa de negociación en
curso con el gobierno colombiano
pasamos ahora a Estados Unidos allí los
nuevos integrantes del Congreso elegidos
durante las elecciones del medio término
de noviembre presentarán juramento para
tomar posesión de sus cargos a partir de
ahora los republicanos dominarán la
cámara de representantes y los
demócratas el senado Qué significa esto
para lo que queda del gobierno del
presidente biden se lo preguntamos a
Cristóbal Vázquez nuestro corresponsal
en la ciudad de Washington o la
Cristóbal Muy buenas tardes para usted y
está reacomodación digamoslo así de las
cargas en las dos cámaras del congreso
de Estados Unidos como repercute para la
gobernabilidad del país y para la
relación entre el presidente biden su
gobierno con el legislativo
se espera una parálisis legislativo una
parálisis política acá en Washington
porque la cámara de representantes es
normalmente la que propone proyectos de
ley que después pasan al senado y
después a la presidencia para su firma
sin embargo ahora que la cámara de
representantes está en mayoría de los
republicanos y el senado de la mayoría
demócrata pues entonces va a haber una
parálisis ahí y va a ser muy poca las
leyes y los proyectos de ley que se van
a poder aprobar Joe biden desde el
ejecutivo tendrá la opción de seguir
avanzando su agenda política en cambio
climático contra la inflación y a favor
de proveer servicios de salud y
educación un poco más asequibles al
pueblo estadounidense a través de
órdenes ejecutivas pero pues es de
Resaltar esa parálisis que muchos
esperan en los próximos dos años va a
ocurrir acá en Washington además de
Resaltar también que en este momento se
llevó a cabo la votación para confirmar
el presidente de la cámara de
representantes
dijo que no va a tener los votos
suficientes para lograr estas este este
los 218 escaños necesarios para
confirmarse y la votación se alargará
entonces en la tarde o en la noche para
lograr esta mayoría Y definir Entonces
el próximo presidente de la cámara de
representantes republica Gracias
Cristóbal por este reporte desde la
ciudad de Washington y atentos al
desarrollo de este par de noticias allí
en la capital de Estados Unidos vamos
ahora hasta china allí los hospitales
siguen recibiendo una enorme afluencia
de personas contagiadas de Kobe 19 La
ola de contagios ha llevado a Que varios
países en el mundo hayan optado por
poner restricciones a Los viajeros
procedentes de este país asiático estas
medidas han sido criticadas por Beijing
dado que consideran que responden a
intereses políticos el informe es de
nuestra compañera Manuela Cano
cama repletas y una larga lista de
espera marcan el panorama de los
hospitales en Shanghai a medida que los
casos de contagios en China desde que el
gobierno acabó con su política de cero
covid un panorama por el que la OMS ha
demandado al país asiático que publique
sus datos sobre el crecimiento de las
infecciones
no prestó mucha atención a los datos
pero definitivamente se están retrasando
y habrá algunos que no se reportarán
definitivamente no hay forma de evitar
esto
la falta de cifras veraces y el temor de
una nueva oleada han llevado a muchos
países occidentales a implementar
medidas para Los viajeros provenientes
de China unas restricciones que han sido
condenadas por el país asiático por
supuestamente responder a motivos
políticos
esto no tiene base científica de algunas
prácticas son inaceptables nos oponemos
firmemente a todos los intentos de
manipular las medidas de prevención de
epidemias para lograr objetivos
políticos tomaremos contra medidas
basadas en el principio de reciprocidad
unas declaraciones que se dan en el
marco del anuncio de la Unión Europea
del ofrecimiento de vacunas al gigante
asiático la comisaria kiriakide se ha
acercado a sus homólogos chinos para
ofrecerles solidaridad y apoyo de la
Unión Europea y esto incluye experiencia
en salud pública así como a través de
vacunas adaptadas por variantes de la
Unión Europea una propuesta que aún no
ha sido aceptada por china que ha estado
inoculando su población con sus propias
vacunas unas que usan la tecnología del
virus inactivado y no aquella del ARN
mensajero utilizada en buena parte de
occidente que ha demostrado una alta
eficacia
en otros temas en Ucrania un grupo de
voluntarios se propuso encontrar y
exhumar los cuerpos de cientos de
soldados que murieron defendiendo a su
país mientras que la guerra continúa y
dificulta aún más la búsqueda de los
restos entre tanto la fiscalía de este
país reveló información sobre el
hallazgo de otra cámara de torturas en
la región de Nicolás que ya fue liberada
de la presencia de las tropas rusas
Andrés triviño tiene los detalles
en un peligroso recorrido por los
frentes de batalla en Ucrania la misión
Tulipán negro un grupo de alrededor de
100 voluntarios se propuso buscar y
exhumar los cuerpos de soldados caídos
en combate para devolverlos a sus
familias Y darles un último adiós
mientras que los ataques continúan
cuando nos sentamos a nuestros muchachos
creo que estamos haciendo una buena obra
pueden ser enterrados adecuadamente
según la tradición ya sea en el Rito
funerario cristiano o la otra creencia
no deben quedar abandonados en algún
bosque campo o en la calle
entre tanto la fiscalía ucraniana
informó sobre el hallazgo de otra cámara
de tortura en la región de nikolife
liberada de la ocupación rusa según el
reporte oficial cientos de civiles
fueron detenidos y torturados
brutalmente por negarse a cooperar con
las tropas rusas mientras que la guerra
se mantiene activa en el este y el sur
del país las labores de identificación
de cadáveres son peligrosas ya que a
menudo se encuentran cuerpos con restos
de armas explosivas o incluso trampas
las circunstancias actuales son
incomprensibles no puedo entenderlas
estamos en El Siglo 21 hay Guerra y los
cuerpos yacen a lo largo de las
carreteras en los bosques y en los
edificios en ruinas
la misión Tulipán negro ya había
realizado labores de identificación de
restos humanos de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial en Alemania encontrando más de
3000 cuerpos ahora en Ucrania La
cantidad es incalculable y Su futuro
incierto
es todas las noticias siga con nosotros
buenas tardes
[Música]